[Música]
revista de prensa en directo América de
Francia 24 y abrimos esta revista de
prensa con Rosa Pérez mateu por supuesto
y un reportaje sobre el Boom de las
bodas en Rusia pero mejor vamos a
dejarlo para después para iniciar con un
tema digamos Rosa que vamos a tratar
precisamente con nuestro invitado del
día y es que las elecciones en Israel ya
se están llevando a cabo Buenos días
Raúl exactamente y hemos seleccionado un
par de medios empezamos por Al jazeera
que está haciendo un Life es decir estas
actualizaciones no que minuto a minuto
van informando sobre las novedades que
hay por ejemplo en una jornada electoral
pero al jazeera decide no solamente
informar sobre hechos no que estén
ocurriendo a lo largo de la jornada sino
también que en este feed no en esta
lista plantea a algunas opiniones entre
ellas destaca la opinión de marwan
bisara quien es una lista senior de esta
de este medio de comunicación a catarín
que destaca que las elecciones en Israel
son ridículas y que la democracia es
ficticia esta es la opinión del analista
bisara dice el poderoso ejército de
Israel y Su economía en auge son hechos
innegables pero su muy celebrada
democracia es pura ficción no y es que
es ciertamente Israel muchas veces es
calificado como la única democracia de
medio oriente sin embargo señala este
analista que bien haya sobre todo el
tema de la parhate y de la ocupación no
ilegal del territorios palestinos pues
ponen en evidencia que no se respetan
los Derechos Humanos como debería ser en
una democracia plena no Y para mencionar
algunos de los párrafos dice Israel ni
siquiera reconoce la israelidad como
nacionalidad el estado judío reconoce
dos estratos de personas los judíos que
tienen plenos derechos y los palestinos
que deben contentarse con menos o ningún
derecho no y como bien enseñábamos hay
algunas leyes por ejemplo como la de
2018 que señaló que solo los judíos
tienen derecho a la autodeterminación
que implican un régimen que como bien
comentábamos tanto amnistía
internacional como human right watch and
señalado como discriminatorio y como
régimen de apartheid y de hecho no una
de las críticas es que cerca de tres
millones de personas que viven bajo
gestiona no del estado de Israel no
tienen derecho a votar por las
autoridades que van a regir su vida en
los territorios palestinos ocupados
Bueno ahora entonces qué dice el
diario.es rosa Pues el diario punto es
tiene una colaboración como hemos
mencionado otras veces con el medio
británico de Garden Y en este caso es
una pieza que ha sido traducida
directamente desde este medio de
comunicación británico y dice elecciones
en Israel la abstención de La minoría
árabe clave para el regreso de la
extrema derecha de netanyahu Y es que
este como no ha sido uno de los puntos
más ha comentados este posible regreso
del que ha sido el Primer Ministro que
más tiempo ha pasado al frente del
gobierno de Israel hablamos de Benjamín
netan Yahoo que está acusado de delitos
de corrupción y que regresar al poder le
podría implicar una inmunidad al menos
Durante este eventual nuevo mandato y lo
que plantea este artículo de The
Guardian Es que la abstención no entre
la población árabe que tiene derecho al
voto en Israel podría aumentar hasta en
un 60% podría alcanzar el 60%. dice para
la mayoría de los árabes que no importa
quien esté pues al frente del ejecutivo
israelíes naftalí bennett
benjamina netanyahu con una coalición de
Ultra Ultra ortodoxos o con la gente
todavía más de extrema derecha que él
como himar Ven al gobierno lo que
estábamos comentando con Federico dice
para ellos la ocupación y la
discriminación continúa la misma sin
embargo hay otra corriente dentro de los
árabes israelíes que sí que aboga por
tener la máxima representación posible
dentro del parlamento y así poder
influir en este caso señalan dentro de
un eventual bloque liderado por Yahir
lapiz digamos menos radical más
centralista no y digamos gestionar
ciertas cosas como por ejemplo el acceso
a la zona de alaxa o Pues el tema de
Jerusalén este o los territorios
ocupados no levantar asentamientos que
son considerados ilegales incluso por
Naciones Unidas bueno dejamos Entonces
Hablado el tema de Israel es rosa y
ahora sí vamos con lo que estaba
adelantando al principio este Boom de
las bodas en Rusia porque está pasando
esto bien lo que está sucediendo no es
que tal y como señala algunos de los
casos en este artículo del Moscú Times
muchas parejas se están casando en el
momento que el chico de la pareja
heterosexual se entiende es
a pues al reclutamiento no para ir a
luchar a Ucrania y bien lo que plantea
este artículo del Moscú Times son
algunas de las razones por las que las
parejas están casando rápidamente si
bien en algunos casos es una cuestión de
sentimentalismo no una forma de forjar a
esta Unión antes de separarse
físicamente para muchas otras es una
cuestión pragmática Y es que lo que
destaca este medio de comunicación es
que teniendo en cuenta que Putin no y el
clement en general sabían que la medida
iba la medida de la reclutamiento de la
movilización parcial militar Y va a ser
polémica han compensado con ciertos
incentivos económicos no a las familias
de los soldados movilizados para dar
algunos ejemplos las familias cuyo padre
o marido no ha sido mandado al frente
reciben transporte público gratuito
también ayudas para los hijos y para las
hijas y una compensación de unos
millones de rublos lo que equivaldríaba
a más de 81 mil dólares en caso de
muerte de la Familiar no del padre o de
la marido en combate Y esta es una de
las razones que está llevando a mucha
gente a formalizar su Unión de hecho
destaca el Times que incluso ha habido
llamadas de mujeres separadas no
oficialmente divorciadas para transmitir
a las autoridades Cuál es el paradero de
sus maridos que en algunos casos pues
quizás no estaban enviando no a su mujer
o a su exmujer la pues la compensación
para los hijos la ayuda la manutención
no que se diría bien en una situación un
poco caótica En todo caso este artículo
se centra en el caso de Anastasia y olek
que ella dice tengo emociones
encontradas fue muy extraño celebrar
este acontecimiento sin nuestra familia
y es que ellos por ejemplo se casaron en
ya dentro de una base militar porque
cuando decidieron no ir al altar por
decirlo así ya
había sido llamado a al frente no
entonces lo que está sucediendo es que
según la ley rusa una pareja tiene que
transmitir a las autoridades al registro
civil con un mes de anticipación
aproximadamente su deseo de casarse no
de formalizar la unión pero ahora las
autoridades rusas lo que están
permitiendo es que el hecho de que el
hombre de la pareja sea enviado al
frente se ha movilizado sea una
excepción no una fuerza mayor que
permita agilizar los trámites de hecho
las autoridades están ayudando a las
parejas a casarse de forma expresa no
por ejemplo también habla este artículo
de bodas masivas no de bodas en grupo
como entrante petesburgo A mediados de
octubre cuando 43 parejas se casaron a
la vez bueno Rosa entonces Muchísimas
gracias como siempre por esta revista de
prensa y nosotros pues vamos a empezar a
analizar así realizando Mejor dicho lo
que viene de cara para estas elecciones
de medio térmi no en Estados Unidos
Gracias Rosa